>> Knowing your family history can help
determine medical information as well as other
general traits. But it can also help you trace your past, From close to distant.
>> Now, because of evolution we know that
were all connected at the very least as
cousins. But, obviously we look more like some
of our family members than we do others.
>> Now discovering all of your different
genetic connections deep within your family tree can
be really difficult. So you'll need a genetic
genealogist to help you with this. They can
help you make all of these complex connections.
>> And, moreover, you don't need a, a specialized graduated degree or,
even a specialized degree in genetics at all to do this job.